don't you just love setting up your
computer
installing libraries configuring them
and making sure they're all compatible
it's it's just so much fun no yeah me
neither
that's why we're gonna skip around all
of that nonsense today using deep
learning VM images on Google compute
engine
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the arts science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're gonna check
out how to take advantage of deep
learning VM images to make setting up a
new environment a piece of cake the
Google cloud deep learning VM image
makes it easy and fast to instantiate a
VM image containing the most popular
deep learning and machine learning
frameworks all on a Google compute
engine instance unless you launch
compute engine instances pre-installed
with your choice of nl frameworks like
test flow or even pi torch and you can
easily add cloud TPU and of course GPU
support you can either instantiate the
image using the Google cloud platform
cloud launcher UI or from the command
line so now you get to use your favorite
open-source tools even sooner without
having to keep them up to date or deal
with installation troubles the deep
learning VM images are prepackaged as a
click to deploy virtual machine that can
be accessed in the marketplace formerly
known as cloud launcher search for deep
learning VM and select launch on compute
engine there you can select from a
number of different deep learning VM
images with configurations of CPU memory
storage GPU and your choice of installed
libraries there are just a ton of
combinations available and you can fine
tune them for your specific workload the
best part is that unlike a typical
computer under your desk the hardware
for a VM can be edited at a moment's
notice need more memory double to this
space or say another GPU or 4 just edit
away let's take a look at how you can
create these VMs
using the G cloud command line tool we
will start with the simpler case of a
virtual machine with only CPU no GPU in
this case we just need to decide what
zone to put our VM in and what machine
learning library we want to use with it
here is the list of all the available
images to choose from let's say we do TF
- latest - CPU the full command to run
this would look something like this and
once you run this it will take a moment
to provision the machine and install all
the software packages once the VM is up
and running you can SSH into the machine
instead of a standard SSH command I
recommend using this slightly modified
SSH command which does a bit of port
forwarding for you to enable you to
connect to Jupiter lab via your local
Chrome browser just like you are running
it locally now when you run this command
it'll drop you into an SSH session you
can poke around there and the command
line if you'd like but the real good
stuff awaits in your browser head over
to the local host
- 8080 and it'll magically load up
Jupiter lab or just be there now we can
do a whole separate video in just
Jupiter lab alone but in brief it's like
Jupiter notebooks but way cooler you can
manage your entire data science workflow
from here running multiple notebooks in
different tabs and with different
versions of Python even and take some
notes say in a text file okay so that's
the end to end workflow for a CPU
powered virtual machine now let's say we
want GPUs because seems like everyone
wants GPUs these days there are a few
additional considerations here that
you'll need to keep in mind as you work
through this process
the tricky part of doing all of this is
that you need to coordinate just a
couple of things to get these GPUs
working right first let's take a look at
what GPUs are available as of this
recording there are our options that
include the K 80 the P 100 and the V 100
so you'll need to perhaps do a little
bit of research to choose which one you
want to use once you've decided on your
GPU of choice check out what regions a
given GPU is available you can see that
shown
here and finally head over to your
quotas page in cloud console to ensure
that you have enough quota to provision
a machine with that combination of GPU
in that zone this final step is crucial
to getting your VM provisioned as
successfully if you don't have the
necessary quota go ahead and click on
edit quotas and submit a quarter request
on the surface it seems to be all about
having the necessary quota but it's a
bit more nuanced than that since the
quota specifies not only what model of
creepy you but also what region that GPU
sits in okay so say you figured out what
chip you want what zone it should be in
and confirm that you have the necessary
quota to provision it now let's look at
how to actually get a GPU powered deep
learning VM going the step that differs
from all the previous CPU workflow that
we just saw is how we actually start up
the VM we can take the command that we
use before and add to it a few extra
more arguments first we need to set the
maintenance policy to terminate this is
due to the fact that we can't live
migrate a GPU power virtual machine so
for maintenance it'll actually shut down
the VM but you can have it auto restart
so always be sure to save your work next
choose your GPU type and count informed
by that quota deep-dive we just did and
finally add a piece of metadata which
will ensure that the drivers to power
your GPU are installed on your behalf
it's a couple of additional steps to get
these GPU powered VMs working but I
promise it's worth the effort once you
run this command the rest the workflow
is exactly the same and when you SSH
into your machine Jupiter lab is there
waiting for you and if you do a pip
freeze you can see that the version of
tensorflow that is installed is indeed
tensorflow
- GPU so the next time you're thinking
about installing a bunch of libraries by
hand remember to save yourself some time
and energy by using the deep learning vm
images on Google cloud platform thanks
for watching this episode of cloud AI
adventures and if you enjoyed it please
like it and subscribe to get all the
latest episodes right when they come out
now head on over your console one make
yourself a deep learning environment in
the cloud
[Music]